welcome back to new rockstar some
recently released concept art for
spider-man no way home teased some of
the things that could have been in that
film including the return of a certain
villain with a fishbowl for a head but
could it be true could quentin beck
still be alive out there in the universe
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
going wrong with me today is the friend
to villains throughout the universe it
is jessica clemens what's going on jess
how the hell's villains do i love it and
i love that introduction and i want
nothing less than that going forward the
friend to all villains i love it
i love it who's the bestie who's my
bestie
i guess agatha but is she really a
villain you know at the end of the day
she's cool brenda villains trying to
build me like she's like she's a cool
villain yeah just wants to be strong
like her mom this is totally fine and of
course the master of her own visual
illusions it's angelica trey what's
going on
yeah it's good to be back i don't know
why i did the wave
hey we are doing the wave let's just
pass it along everybody
and of course our very own researcher
supreme one of the smartest and most
amazing people on the planet ready to
take on any challenge it's whitney van
landingham what's going on
oh man that was so nice look at you just
being a sweet little bean
fresh fresh this morning look at you
that's why i'm baldwin i'm just one big
old pinto beach that's what i'm doing
here i'm doing a pinto bean cosplay i
don't know what i'm saying but anyway
now that we've got some room from the
release of spiderman no way home marvel
and sodi have started to put out a ton
of the scenes content and this includes
some concept art from the early days of
production on the film and one of these
images revealed a different direction
the plot could have gone to so this
leads us to our first topic of the day
how could mysterio have been worked into
spider-man no way home because some
concept art from spider-man no way home
came out this week showing doctor
strange battling mysterio at the statue
of liberty but that plot line was
obviously not in the film unless you
watch a totally different film sorry
that was a bootleg you should probably
get your money back but how could
mysterio have played a role in no way
home would he have replaced another
villain and more importantly would this
have been the same mysterio from the mcu
or a mysterio from a different universe
and does this mean that quentin beck is
still out there alive in the mcu uh
gaslighting everybody that he meets what
do you guys think i think that if he had
ended up in the movie i think that he
would have ended up taking the place of
green goblin because in the same sense
that like peter's trying to right the
wrong of killing mysterio so i think
that replacing him with green goblin and
having peter not kill him this time
around
um would have been like a cool little
redemption arc for pdpd uh but i'm also
wondering what if it's like what if like
the real quentin beck actually came and
not this like fake ass one from the mcu
like what if it's the earth like the
actual earth 616 guy showed up
this is true because like what what it
is referring to is that the fact that we
don't actually know what jake
gyllenhaal's name is in the mcdo he's
not actually quentin he's not the real
one
he gasled a bunch of people even us into
believing that he was actually quentin
back but he's not actually put them back
so is there an actual one out there
that's really good i like that yeah man
i think the real clinton bet could have
shown up and been that uh that
spider-man surrogate for
he doesn't kill him this time and he's
redeemed for not murdering mysterio or
whatever yeah that'd be very funny
that'd be so funny if that quinn beck
showed up and then it was just like
or
the variants of a mysterio
show up and it's like
one of mysterious is the actual quentin
back and it's like uh i don't know why
i'm here
i'm just like look hey i have to go pick
up my kids from daycare i cannot leave
now
killer one portal please i gotta go i
gotta go back i won't say anything you
don't have to kill me but let me go
that's very funny that kind of is
adjacent to my original theory that i
think in that art they did have did
intend for him to come out of the portal
and possibly fight the people that
cracked at the liberty the statue of
liberty i think that first those people
were supposed to make much higher of an
impression than what they did but they
were probably like this is too much to
chaoticness also to have to tie in all
of the original people coming out of
those purple cracks to the future of the
mcu they'd be like this is too much for
the spider-man plot line well we don't
need to start it here let's just have
them kind of be shadowed out they can
have their theories of who comes out of
what but i think originally
he was gonna come out and fight mysterio
um but they were like let's grab it we
already have 700 other things going on
but i do like the idea of what whitney
said of him taking on the green goblin
roll because
and i've been drinking coffee all day so
i could be spaced but he didn't
technically he didn't technically have
an enemy r peter our peter parker
technically didn't have someone show up
right yeah this is that mysterious thing
to an arch that he had exactly so that
would be nice if every villain of peter
parker came out and this one that did
die did come back from a different
timeline and be like you killed me
i was
i said
joe john jonah jameson after you but
like yeah i agree with whitney too
that'd be that'd be great it would just
be really fun to see dr strange and
quentin beck fighting in their little
capes just doing little cape battles at
the top of the statue of liberty
all over the place mysterio would lose
so quick
oh he would lose so many yeah
it was a good fight the moon that
stephen was in that night like oh
absolutely not i would not have messed
with stephen whatsoever oh no he's
cranking but however he was sort of
distracted with the whole dealing with
the crack situation that is true he
could have sucker punched him real quick
that is honestly honestly and that's the
that's the um
not the heel whatever they call in
wrestling that's what they needed um was
that like he's too busy trying to crack
all these back it or close them then you
just get punched in the ribs repeatedly
by the stereo so it could it could have
been an even match then i think that's
what he needed in order to defeat dr
strange that could be true that could be
true i like it yeah okay originally when
i i saw that um concept art too i
thought maybe that mysterio just kind of
slipped through the cracks during that
final fight and i thought it was a
really cool idea because mysterio is
sort of like this old school feeling
magician at least in my mind because he
does
illusions whereas doctor strange is
using using actual magic so i thought
that would be a really cool dynamic but
at the same time that is the only tom
holland villain
that would have been introduced in here
in no way home so it would have felt a
little weird and probably a little i
don't know like there's just this one
and if that's the case then what would
stop i don't know like thanos or
something from being brought back if
we're doing the tom holland anyone that
knows that's true
peter parker type scenario that's true i
like the idea of the visual of
a mysterio slipping through the cracks
because he is sneaky and like out of all
of the villains
they're like how did you get out he's
like i slipped through this crash he's
like he's like
hello
remember me
like he like disguises himself like his
little fishbowl head and he like yeah
himself in like a row of street lamps
you know like as well i would yes
i see i can see you you're a straight
lamp yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
i like what you said about thanos
because ebby neymar for sure knows who
peter parker is and peter parker is
basically the one who killed him i mean
it was tony stark in infinity war but
like it was his idea with aliens so um
ebony ma could theoretically be in the
mcu right now who knows um but i do like
that point for sure um with with thanos
i've i've always been of the mind of
mysterio obviously before this movie
come out i i thought that was that toby
mcguire and andrew garfield were going
to be mysterio illusions so like having
this like you know
about it
makes me feel good that like i'm not
completely crazy
how would you dario know about the other
peter parkers i guess then if he was
like going to be illusions of them would
he just have well like
no go go go like after all the sinister
six guys escaped at the at that point in
the movie they could have just met up
with him back and told him everything
about the expirement
oh true true true okay and like you know
those two spider-men were swinging
around for like a day before they they
met up with that is true they found
andrew garfield in literal uh ally yeah
no they like those two spiderman were
definitely like [ __ ] i gotta check out
the pizza in this universe and then i
will go play with
such a horrible job because andrew
garfield stayed in costume
in the universe where he is the number
one like fbi wanted and he's just like i
know i got my little suit on i'll punch
you
here i am someone come rob me
[Laughter]
oh andrew but no these are all amazing
ideas but i'm going to give the rogue
point to whitney i love the idea of the
real quentin back coming back because
like we don't know
if quentin beck was inspired to steal
that name from another person and like i
do have this weird feeling this weird
inclination that the people that
arrested peter parker at the beginning
of no way home were not cops at all and
that was team mysterio
taking the glasses back i had this weird
feeling this weird inclination and that
we're going to see more mysterio later
on they're just i think marvel studios
wants us to forget about mysterio and
just be like all right yeah he's gone
right
just kidding they have the glasses and
they're preparing to just to trick him
again
so i hope that happens again and i hope
i honestly um hope that we see like an
old man logan type thing in the future
of the mcu where mysterio is the person
that tricks wolverine into
killing all the x-men because i do i
think that mysterio would be such a
we're giving we're so good in a real old
man logan situation you're giving
mysterio too much credit he is like the
kite man
[Laughter]
my most recognizable impersonation
[Laughter]
mysterio is literally just one big
illuminati street lamp that's basically
all he is but up next we're going to
talk about a mysterious new character in
the next guardians of the galaxy film
but first check out the book of boba
fett inspired shirt over at
newrockstarsmerch.com it has a really
cool design you'll see eric wearing it
on our weekly wikileaks show with tommy
the most beautiful man in the world
they've also got some merch inspired by
peacemaker spiderman far from home
spiderman no way home and everything
else that you're into so check out all
of our cool awesome new rockstars merch
over at newrockstarsmerge.com
or else nothing or else i'll love you
either way that's all i don't know why i
was gonna threaten you there but that's
that's not good that's not that's how we
sell things in america well sometimes i
guess but not here when i've got my
stance socks on i know my feet are both
comfortable and stylish and now they're
taking that comfort and style from toe
to head with the launch of their all-new
active apparel line stance has a super
soft line of sweatpants and joggers
shirts hoodies and more that look as
good as they feel and they're available
in the full range of fits prints and
fabrics i think the coolest part about
stance apparel is all of their
collaborations with artists and ip wear
their nightmare before christmas hoodie
over their bob marley tv shirt with
incredible hulk socks and let the world
know all the stuff that you're into at
the same time because why not be
efficient okay don't be inefficient with
how you wear your clothes stan's
philosophy is that you should never have
to sacrifice your own individual style
for the sake of comfort and now you
don't have to so whether you're relaxing
around the house working out at the gym
or running all over town stance now
delivers its signature softness and
creativity in a full line of active
apparel styles from toe to head stance
has got you covered so head on over to
stance.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use promo code rogue at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance
stitched different and look we're not
always confident in our theories here in
rogue theory but you need confidence in
life and also in the bedroom if humanity
is going to continue that is where blue
chew comes in blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets at a fraction of
the cost you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises if it's
now next week or in my case 2072 the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and it's all
done online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discrete package so if you
could benefit from extra confidence when
it's time to perform blue chew can help
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth for free when use
our promo code rogue at checkout just
pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechu.com promo code rogue to receive
your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank blue chew for sponsoring this show
now moving on if you haven't been
checking out peacemaker on hbo max i
highly suggest you do my buddy my good
friend james gunn made it and it is one
of the best things that the dcu has ever
made so go watch that what are you doing
but also i've been breaking down the
series here on your rockstar so you know
here's my shameless plug for that but an
actor from peacemaker is about to show
up in the mcu so there you go so that
leads us to our second topic for today
who is this new character in guardians
of the galaxy volume 3
james gunn has cast actor chikudi awuji
who is currently playing mirn on
peacemaker in an unknown role in the
upcoming guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
and no one is you know quite sure or
officially sure who this character is
but in an interview this week with
jakubiowuji uh he described the
character as one of the most complex
characters that we've seen in the
freaking marvel universe like deeply
complex and deeply powerful so
what do you guys think this character
could be i
have
three theories but i wanna hear the two
of yours first you guys because i know
both of you probably will take them
high evolutionary man
i think he's gonna be high evolutionary
yeah
i will i at first i i thought i'd love
to see him as silver surfer but i
figured unless they're gonna do some
sort of post-credit scene you know
leading into the fantastic four or
teasing that in some sense
um
i was thinking
about some of the previous news that i
heard about
uh volume three
based around rocket raccoon's like
history and so i figured it might have
something to do with that like
like some sort of sciency character a
geneticist so i could definitely see
high evolutionary
because
that character if you go into rockets
like history
would be
like if you go into like backstories and
stuff in volume 3 of guardians of the
galaxy
then you might get to see that
characters come up and then just see him
super powerful later on and the
guardians have to fight him i could
definitely see that
wasn't the original
the the guy that played high
evolutionary
can't remember his name the scientist
didn't it wasn't his whole thing
basically like yo we can splice humans
with the genetics of
like with animal with huma human and
animals but
he did it with his dog and his dog got
like shot
like creatures because they were like
tomorrow yeah so it would work that
raccoon that rocky raccoon which i have
not heard a single thing about so i'm
behind on news yeah yeah that would make
so much sense that he was spliced with
like a human
yeah so high evolutionary his whole
thing is that he rocket raccoon was one
of his experiments
so he actually is responsible for making
rocket raccoon that was like that's one
of the things that he was experimenting
on that got him uh kicked out of oxford
that'll do it to you you make a you make
a weird talking raccoon with with jail
in its body and oxford don't watch you
no more
stealing and shooting people
this thing has been alive for 30 minutes
and it's broken out of five prisons
uh yes and then not only is he uh a
rocket raccoon's uh
daddy if you will his his og papa um he
also played a role
in adam warlock uh emerging from his
cocoon and so because we know that will
poulter is gonna be playing adam warlock
in this
i wonder if that's something we're gonna
we're gonna get to see all these
people's little backstories that we
might that would
that would be fun
if the high
evolutionary is the leader of the
sovereign and giving uh aisha her tools
to make adam warlock so by proxy or
whatever in summary adam warlock and
rocket raccoon are cousins um
yeah they're actually brothers i think
that
that comment has to be made in the movie
and once it is rocket is going to be
like we're not related and adam's gonna
be like
yes we are and he's gonna be like we're
brothers
because he's also brand new he's fresh
to the world he's definitely gonna be
like brother and it's like no yeah
we're just going to just pull like a
full dominic toretto with family
okay so those are both my theories um
the high evolutionary and um silver
surfer i would just love to see the
silver surfer come back but same you
guys want to go rogue
you want to stay in the box but go rogue
with my
so let's say he is the high evolutionary
but let's say
that we are forgetting
that kang the conqueror existed and he
said there's a million variants of
himself that are taking over different
worlds so what if one of his variants is
the high evolutionary because he is not
only the smartest man on the planet but
he his offsprings of himself if you want
to call the variants that could just be
even more chaotic but also as smart so
what if um the high evolutionary is one
of the kang's variants just coming over
to destroy
uh what is not normal what's not what
what he doesn't perceive as perfect
so
that's what i think it's kind of the
conquerors
variant that is the high evolutionary
that would be ins that would be crazy
it's highly plausible too because given
like you said given the direction that
the mcu was going with with all these
kang variants it would be i i think
shakuta would you would make an amazing
king variant you would even
knock it out of the park
because like this character um herbert
windham is super super smart and like
much like uh nathaniel richards is in
the comics so i can definitely them and
like the actual look of the high
evolutionary is sort of like he sort of
gives me scarlet centurion vibes that
scarlet centurion is another variant of
kang in the marvel comics so i can
definitely i can definitely see them
adapting that in that way just being
like oh yeah this is just like the the
purple centurion so i think i think
we're all just in agreement with the
high evolutionary huh
yeah i think yeah
oh yeah i think
it makes sense more than i would love
the idea of the silver surfer coming
because galactus come back and but it's
i think it's still too soon and i fought
with ian about this my boyfriend i
fought with him about it because i was
like i just don't think they would bring
in the fantastic four they would open
the door through the guardians of the
galaxy three i would love that to be the
case but i just don't think they're
gonna give james gunn that much power um
yeah and and that's that's just me
that's me they and when it and when i'm
showing up hell yeah more to you but
like i just don't think it's the time i
don't think it's the time it it's it's a
doctor strange level thing it's an
avengers level thing to invite the
fantastic four in and i think by just
allowing silver surfer and you're
already being like they're coming so
yeah
not in guardians of the galaxy three but
i want i want the silver surfer and i
went with that theory like immediately
because i was just like please
please and you could just leave the
fantastic four out you could just bring
it in galactus just make it a galactic
silver surfer thing but i just don't see
it
yeah no people are gonna make those ties
for sure well these are all amazing
theories well in regards to like what i
think i definitely agree with you guys
it's gonna be the high evolutionary and
i think all the signs are there in
particular with uh rocket raccoon and
particularly how yondu speaks to rocket
raccoon in our guardians of the valley
in in guardians of the galaxy vol 2
because he only pretty much calls rocket
a rat
and herbert wyndham in the comics
evolves these animals called his new men
from rats so he's making all these like
animal-type people from rats so the
reason why yondu calls rocket a rat
exclusively is because he knows about
his past as a radio
that is
got it i'm giving me the point and i
think that you know the key to you know
guardians of the galaxy volume 3 is
going to be
that energy the annual x batteries from
um from aisha's planet the sovereign um
because
if you look at eternals and like with
the bat what the main bad guy of
eternals was doing he was sucking this
this orange juice from the eternals and
slowly evolving as he was doing that
because that juice is evolution energy
and the high evolutionary is going to be
using that evolutionary energy to like
probably bring in mutants to the mcu
this is that's just me and my weird
rogue theory
full circle here wow full circle hooray
um but that's just me but i gotta reward
these points and you know what i'm
giving i know i always do this
i'm gonna give everybody the points
because you guys all just basically said
i evolutionary which is great and i i
100 agree with you because you guys
i was
the treasurer of the united states of
america we would be in debt with aliens
several aliens
i'd still appoint you up there
thank you yeah i would too i i would not
mt head of aliens
because
jessica loves america she knows that i
would destroy this country no no no not
today why i would appoint you to the
alien liaison for yeah
so canada can absorb us he wouldn't give
me points if he became the leader of
america
he wouldn't give me any points
i'll give you a tax break which is good
for you oh wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute i need that i need that
don't even start
okay never mind you got my vote so now
it is time for our road question because
today january 28th was supposed to be
morbius day the day that morbius was
supposed to premiere in theaters but
instead sony has pushed the date back to
april so instead pitch me your rogue's
most insane storylines for a version of
morbius that would have come out today i
think
a rogue idea for what morbius was
actually gonna be i feel like they
pushed it um not for covin not for
anything
behind the scenes uh because they wanted
to change the plot line entirely from
what it i my theory is i think the
original plot line was morbius was um as
a vampire yes but he also just runs the
subway train that runs underground and
he's just a normal bus man and that's
why we see so many scenes at the subway
station because he's constantly working
and he's doing so much stuff and i think
all of it is just clues of like look at
the graffiti art look at all these
things he's doing everything underground
let's keep in mind he's a vampire i know
that we're like yeah he's kind of like
blade though he can go out day no he
can't he actually couldn't in the
original plot line of this movie he had
to stay only at night so he lives in the
underground i keep wanting to say
underground railroad he works
with aries
he works on the underground right with
cynthia for the cynthia avario that
played harriet tubman and uh they kind
of free all the slaves and i know what
you're thinking uh morbius freeing
slaves oh what that's crazy jessica um
let's keep in mind that it's one week
from black history month so they were
planning for this
february 28th and then by february 1st
y'all would have been like oh another
white savior
that's my seriousness that's like
they're taking it off oh my god
you know what i'm taking it i think
you're actually 100 correct it's not
even that rogue because that's exactly
what was going to happen
so the plot is that
would help harriet tubman that's what
you think yeah i think that you just
confirmed that harriet tubman is a
vampire
[Laughter]
all right what do you guys got so okay
so um
uh wacky wacky theories i don't know if
i can top that one but
so yeah
what if uh morbius so morbius vampire
what if he keeps
changing
in this plot right so he keeps morphing
and changing and eventually he becomes a
giant bat he is man bat
batman comes in there's a crossover it's
crazy it's wild things are happening
batmobile is going around yeah things
are it's it's intense
i love man so that's my point that gets
my damn point that gets yeah i look for
any reason to include man bat in
literally everything every aspect of my
life i used to love man bat until
arkham's uh the third arkham game where
he scares the crap out of you
randomly
because he's so it's so stupid but then
seeing him in the actual harley quinn
series i was like he's even more stupid
and um
i'm here for villains and i'm here for
stupid and that man is stupid and i love
them i'm all about it love them
good stuff what about you whitney okay
so i'm gonna uh strong agree that the
reason the trailer didn't come out today
is because they decided to reshoot the
whole entire movie and here's what they
did they decided that morbius
too dark and gritty kids kids want to
laugh they want they want their giggles
so
they re-shot all of morbius in the
mockumentary style of what we do in the
shadows and they invited laszlo and
nandor and now
all the guys kristen schall's there i
don't know they're all just uh i would
love that they take more beers under
their wings once he becomes a vampire
you know he needs help he needs help
adjusting to vampire life so he's like
oh god who can help me and then like
laszlo is like come here sir you
i will i will take you under my wing and
then uh morbius learns how to be a good
boy
from
the vampires over at what we do in the
shadows i need to see matt berrius right
now i don't want to see morbius i want
to see matt i want to see matt berry
training morbius
exactly the true origin story
can we bring back peter the old vampire
from the movie does anyone remember him
yes yes
yes we absolutely can bring that okay
thank you okay it's cool
pete wait who's peter isn't peter that
was the old one he was the oldest one
from the movie he's not the chef he was
useless he was not useless in a bad way
no he was killing people they had to
keep him in the room because he kept
just like trying to kill people yeah
he had a jumper yeah he had to like
throw chickens at him just for him to
like
survive
well okay well these are all amazing
answers but i'm gonna have to give the
rogue points for those to jessica for
her ridiculous answer
um and honestly i'm gonna get i'm gonna
give the win for the day to jessica
because she just nailed it today
jess is our winner for rogue theory
today everyone give her a round of
applause um and you even you at home
because she is a wonderful person
even you guys as well
everybody is a wonderful person
i don't like
rewarding one person over the other
because we all we're all amazing and i
love you guys so much um but yes thank
you guys so much for watching this
episode of rogue theory with all of us
and of course thank you to our wonderful
guests jessica clemens angelica trey and
whitney ben laningham for joining us
support our channel by checking out all
of our awesome merch over at new
rockstarsmerch.com and if you have
thoughts on some of our rogue theories
you can share them on our discord it's
just make sure you're over 18 and search
for new rockstars over at discord and
join the conversation follow me on
mastertainment and follow the rockstars
on all of our social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
youtube we love you guys so much thank
you so much for watching we'll see you
guys later goodbye
[Music]
you